[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys and
welcome back to the lehigh pen show
powered by icon plus so
really quickly for you so icon recently
launched bridge
a direct fiat on and off ramp service
for all
icon dats so newcomers can now bank on
icon without even knowing that they are
using blockchain so very cool
for the icon now like that now i want to
say thank you to my sponsors block fight
i use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so that is
incredibly exciting you can also get 250
when you sign up um so i'm going to
leave the link for you
somewhere and everywhere and a last
quick shout out before i bring on my
guests
to coinflip so you can actually get 10
off their transactions
i'm gonna leave a discount code running
for you in a minute now if you are
watching on youtube please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe
so you never miss any of these fantastic
guests now today
is a pretty interesting guest i'm very
excited to bring him on
he is a um podcaster he's a youtuber it
is
of course btc sessions also known as
ben what's up ben hey i'm i'm great i'm
super excited to be here and there's
just so much going on so
i i can't wait to chat yeah i'm super
excited i think we're
really lucky to be going live right now
because of what is going on
now let's just jump straight into it i
want to give the audience the juice the
chocolate the cake
straight away i don't see any reason to
hold back so
gamestop right that is what's kind of
taken the world by storm not just
the original um traditional financial
markets but it's taking the crypto world
by storm so for those that don't know i
think back in march in 2020
it was trading at around 3.25
now this week i'm not sure what the
price is right this second but i think
it hit above
150 so
gamestop is something is one of those
companies which have just been
unfortunately declining
so tell us why is it going up explain
what is happening
well okay so one of the things that has
happened here is
i mean gamestop yes i i will grant that
the model
it's it's maybe a model that's on its
way out right like the physical
locations where you go to pick up
physical games things are going
very much digital um that said people
still go there
um i've still gone there from time to
time and still utilize it but
but these guys have been uh effectively
shorted
by a lot of these hedge funds um saying
that the stock is going to
crater but it's the amount that they've
been shorting this stock
betting that the stock will go down that
is of particular interest so they were
able to
short this stock for and forty percent
which means
forty percent more than the total
outstanding shares they were able to
take the opposite side of that bet
so what ended up happening is a group of
people on
reddit known as wall street bets saw
this as an opportunity and they said
well hey
you know these guys typically get to set
the rules and they get to do
whatever the hell they want whenever the
hell they want to do it
and there's always just no repercussions
for these guys they
if they screw up bad enough they will
get bailed out by the banks
um and so what they said is let's just
go
buy up buy the hell out of gamestop and
pump it through the roof and actually
that price
point i've seen much higher i've seen it
over 300 i think at one point it was
over 400 like it's it's insane
um so everybody went in and they were
just pumping the hell out of the stock
and these hedge funds were losing
billions of dollars and so what ended up
happening
uh is some of the investors in uh
robin hood app where a lot of people are
buying this stock
are also in in bed with the hedge funds
that were shorting uh we're shorting
gamestop
uh so robin hood has removed
uh gamestop as an option to trade
so what you can do is if you own
gamestop you can sell
it but you cannot buy more so they've
given a one-way street to retail
investors
while hedge funds can strategically uh
mitigate the risk and re-allocate so
that they're
they're safe which never never happens
if somebody in retail is losing money oh
no the the little guy's losing money
don't worry we'll stop the market so you
guys can
can get out okay that has never happened
ever
and was the last time you saw this uh
the trading of
any asset shut down because it was going
up too much
never until the big guys are losing the
money
i love everything that is happening here
because
there's this growing swell of kind of
screw the elites at the top that that
don't get to play by the rules they get
to privatize
the gains and they get to socialize the
losses by getting bailouts which are
paid for
by taxpayers or paid for by inflation
which is a hidden tax
on regular citizens so you know what
this lines up perfectly with the ethos
of bitcoin
and what i'm interested in
and more power to them i think that
these guys
they've got the right mindset i think
that they're they're
poking the bear there
they're definitely stirring stirring
stuff up
um but i i think
what we're seeing now with everybody
effectively being shut out of buying
this
because it's uh stepped on the wrong
toes
is that the whole thing is is
effectively rigged
for the big boys at the top um and the
little guys don't have much of a chance
if they play in their playground what
i'm waiting for
is for these guys to start to recognize
the the underlying problem because right
now they're attacking kind of the
symptoms
and i i guess we can look back to
say 2008 in the financial crisis right
you had a bunch of people playing with
other monies
other people's money making very very
risky
bets and they were doing this because
they didn't think they would get burned
but then when they did get burned
there was actually zero consequence
because we spun up the money printers
and we funneled all that new money back
to make them whole again
and everybody else got left footing the
bill
the reason that was possible is because
the underlying currency itself
can do that you have the function of
being able to turn on those monty
money printers and allocate capital
where
you know the people at the top see fit
and when you get down to it
we're seeing this play out it's shining
a spotlight
on the actual problem right now these
guys are attacking kind of the symptoms
of the underlying problem
but bitcoin is very much
born from that same ethos of
there's something systemically wrong and
we can't fix the system
we can just create a better one that's
why we're here
yeah i think well firstly you explain
that beautifully so
absolutely well done i thought that was
explained really really well i think
you know especially so firstly there are
two things going on here i think
you have um obviously what's going on in
reddit you have the group sort of
pumping up the the price of it but then
you have what we've seen today
robin hood actually sort of jumping in
right
and i think this is going to be the most
insane thing for the space because it
really shows
the need for decentralization and you
have a lot of young people right on apps
like tick tock so on tick tock
you literally have people talking about
different stocks
um you know there's a whole niche and
for generation z
like not just millennials but generation
z wanting to get into the stock market
because i think that
they are sort of switched on that the
game is rage you know we don't really
want the nine to five
there must be a better way you know
we've seen those videos coming onto
um onto twitter people sort of saying
like you know
look what the big guys are doing we've
got to do better you know we're seeing
them sort of talking about these things
but we're not seeing them make that jump
into crypto because crypto still sort of
seen
as this um let's just say i don't know
this dark
uh criminal sort of community or
whatever it is um
but wow the whole the whole deep like
you know it goes into like the whole
deep platforming it goes into
the whole banning and it really just
makes the case for cryptocurrency i
think
um you know this is why we need
decentralized applications this is why
we need somebody that just isn't in
charge you know once
no one single point of failure no one
single centralized
authority um do you think that this is
going to be
a real opportunity for these kind of
people this kind of market
to move into crypto i think it's going
to take time
i think um yeah i
i think that you'll see some people
start to get it but it's
it's a journey right like these these
people they
they managed to find a [ __ ] in the
armor
of of the guys at the top but in
in doing so these guys have effectively
said you're out
you know if you do something we don't
like we will just stop it in its tracks
and so the connection is there to be
made
and i see some people on twitter already
making that connection
obviously with a bunch of bitcoiners
behind them saying hey you know
poking and prodding but i mean yeah
it's amazing good for these guys screw
the guys at the top
i let it burn i'd honestly let it burn
um and the other beautiful thing about
this is
uh there's not a lot that the left and
the right
can agree on but you know what
i've seen and i tend to in terms of
especially like
monetary policy and like the how to fix
some of the problems in our in our
system i tend to
lean a little right on that but i've
seen that
some opposite ends of the spectrum you
have like aoc
and like robert reich who was a an
advisor to clinton
coming out and calling out the same bs
saying
how can robin hood shut down regular
people from buying a stock
while the hedge funds are allowed to
trade it like nothing has happened
and and mitigate all their risk while
everybody else gets put out
it's just there's a double standard here
and both sides of the spectrum see it
it's just how they approach
uh dealing with it you know i i think on
the left
it leans towards more regulations
which i think can be loopholed
eventually
as they have been and i on the right it
tends to lean towards deregulation
um which can hurt in the short term
because scammers can get in there but
um in my opinion i think the only way
around this
is becoming anti-fragile as a system and
as an individual because if you get
burned you're going to learn from that
and you're not going to make that
mistake again
so yeah i think that's such a cool um
observation
and that the left and the right sort of
agree on it because i think you know at
the end of the day
i often find when it comes to politics
um we all sort of want the same goal we
just have different ways of getting
there
and at the end of the day um so i'm the
same as you i fiscally tend to be far
more conservative and on the right um
but we all sort of want a let's call it
a level playing field we all want
fairness we all
you know especially the left that's sort
of what their foundations are right
um and to think that the little man is
absolutely getting screwed
is quite unbelievable um and insane so
you mentioned something earlier which i
just want to kind of um
i guess echo and point out a little bit
more so robin hood
banning the the trading of this so you
said they were in bed with
with people on wall street what's the
connection there so did this come from
wall street or
did it come from robin hood what's the
connection yeah so one of the major i
i i just saw it it was um on an article
it was one of the
little disclaimers underneath it uh but
uh i can't remember which
i think it was um what's the name of the
hedge fund that was getting
capital yeah yeah uh uh melvin or
sorry melvin yeah yeah melvin so so they
are
they have money that they've funneled
into robin hood they helped
with and and have funded robin hood
itself so of course
like given that they have money in the
game of robin hood or rather that
robin hood uh at least has some
influence from melvin capital of course
that's going to be the influence that
comes down there isn't that even like
illegal though like
how can you i'm just i'm just sort of
thinking
like i'm just trying to i kind of get my
words out okay sorry i will get my words
out
so how is that even how is that even
legal right like
it's supposed to be a fair trading
platform so
how can one of the biggest um i don't
know if they're the biggest but how can
such a huge company
have such an investment in a platform it
literally means the game is rigged like
how can you do that that is it's not
insider trading but it's a little bit
like insider trading in some way do you
see what i mean
yeah well i mean the the answer to this
i suppose would just be
more complete transparency on on what
everybody does and you know we don't
typically get that and also
complete and free access uh to anybody
for all of those tools
if you have transparency and access for
everyone
then you can't screw somebody else uh
with an unfair advantage
and yeah so we're just kind of we're at
this place where
there's a set of rules for a certain
group of people and there's a set of
rules for another group of people
and the spotlight has been shown on it
and
i'm sure this isn't the first or the
last that we're going to be hearing
about this and i think the fallout
from this whatever that snowball's into
um
it's going to be felt for some time and
there's going to be a lot of questions
about this moving forward
yeah absolutely especially if it's
something that the left and right can
agree on
i mean i know aoc has a huge amount of
influence so
um this this should be fun i'm excited
um but
let's go let's talk a little bit more
about you so you know everything
um in crypto is very much
american-centric i think most my
audience are based in america
um you know sec everything's america
right um
nothing else matters but you're canadian
so yes um and i can really hear it in
your accent it's fine
i can hear the oh and the the about i
can hear it um
so let like teach me a little bit about
what it's like in canada
um you know what what's it like in terms
of its approach to cryptocurrencies
yeah so i mean for the most part it's
relatively friendly in terms of a
regulatory environment
so um most of now i will say it's a
little bit tighter
than than typical uh money transmitting
laws but
the laws here are uh anything above
a thousand dollars requires an id
um normally for cash like transactions
that is three thousand so we're a little
bit below that
not ideal but better than you know
the worst of the worst and then anything
above ten thousand dollars which is
across the board for any type of asset
is uh the anti-money laundering laws
come into effect so you need
um more id and proof of proof of where
the funds came from things like that so
across the board there it's it's
relatively friendly like it's not not
too cumbersome here
it's pretty open so that's all good now
in terms of the government itself and
how it operates and
the thing like how we operate our money
um
i would say canada is kind of a shining
beacon for why bitcoin exists
uh in in our in our monetary policies i
mean
don't get me wrong the us takes the cake
because holy crap
but pretty much so
right now for example um
the bank of canada and keep in mind that
the size of canada we're like 30 million
plus people so we're like the size of
california in terms of
actual people living here um so
but uh right now the bank of canada has
stated that it will
effectively print or introduce liquidity
into the market
at a wrinkle yeah exactly at least
four billion dollars per week uh
so which is for how long sorry for how
long
for as long as it takes they said until
uh the market is stable and inflation
targets are met
have you done a calculation of how much
that is a year or
uh i i would have to nab can max okay
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's plenty and um our our
national debt clock so there's
there's a an advocacy group that keeps
track of the national debt
and they had a clock ticker um well
it broke because they ran out of digits
recently
they have to add an extra digit because
we passed
yeah we passed the one trillion dollar
mark which again compared to the us
um is is small but for a
relative 30 million people yeah that's
all relative
um our public and private debt
versus the gross domestic product of the
entire country
is at 387 percent so
the amount of productivity in the entire
country
there is uh 387 percent of that
worth of debt in the country which is
insane and just to put it in perspective
this is higher than the greek debt
crisis
and it's higher than the peak of the uh
the housing um and the housing bubble in
the states
um in terms of debt to gdp ratio we're
higher than both of those
so we're on this crash course and beyond
that
um we are the only g7 nation
that has zero gold reserves like like
zip in fact yeah out of the g7 nations
uh were the only one to have less than
100 tons
of gold as a as a reserve we got rid of
it as of 2016 the last of our gold is
gone we sold it all
oh wow yeah it's it's unbelievable so
like
we're in this really precarious spot
where
there's so much debt there's nothing to
back it up
and we're not slowing down i mean the us
is is similar but being a world reserve
currency they probably got a little bit
more of a runway
before they fly off that cliff um we're
probably a little bit closer to that so
i look at those numbers and they scare
the hell out of me uh but
again this is why something like bitcoin
exists because if you're if you're
holding dollars if you're holding
canadian dollars
yeah yeah like why why would you want to
hold those
fiat debt coupons right you you you want
to have like a sound money
um and for me i i live on bitcoin now i
i hold as few dollars as possible so are
you
would you say you're entirely unbanked
or not you're you hold a few dollars to
pay your bills and so on
yeah so do i have a bank account yes uh
i hold as few dollars as possible i get
paid
almost exclusively in bitcoin if
somebody wants to pay me in dollars i
charge a premium
and then i utilize various uh ramps
in order to like all use here in
canada there's a couple options like
bull bitcoin or bitcoin well
and both of those allow you to pay any
bill or fund any bank account
using bitcoin and so i calculate my
bills at the beginning of the month i
say okay this is coming out of this
account
and as soon as i get paid i'll swap it
over so it's sitting there
and the rest that's in savings is
outside of the dollar like i i don't use
it and then i use things like bit refill
or coin cards or whatever to get
day-to-day expenses
and so yeah am i jumping through hoops
absolutely but
at the end of the day i'm not holding
dollars and i'm better off because of it
yeah i'm with you so how do you um just
deal with taxes then so if you get paid
in
bitcoin do you then have to transfer it
to dollars so that you can then
calculate it and then transfer it back
to bitcoin i ask because that's
something i'm personally trying to
figure out myself
yeah so i mean first off i'm not an
accountant so
uh uh i have an accountant uh
no financial advice yeah you're good
yeah disclaimer's done
yeah so so effectively you have to worry
about two different types of taxes
in in that instance so there's there's
income tax right so whatever you got
paid
the dollar equivalent at that moment you
should account for that and you should
probably convert that and have it sit
there for tax time
okay so then that's all dealt with and
you have your your bitcoin that
you is actually spendable that you is
your take-home pay your
your net um whatever you
save of that and whatever you don't
spend immediately on bills or convert
immediately for bills
um if that goes up in value then you
also have to consider capital
gains tax so in canada currently
whatever you make let's say i saved a
thousand dollars worth of bitcoin and it
turned into two thousand dollars worth
of bitcoin
i made an extra thousand dollars and in
canada 50
of that is taxable that doesn't mean
they stealed 50
of it it means that half of that so 500
of the thousand that i made is now
considered as
income and then goes into like my yearly
income
and that gets taxed at whatever my tax
rate is
so just so i understand you pay 50 on
capital gains tax
no so did i misunderstand that no so
so um it's kind of like saying that part
of your income they can only apply
taxes to half of it
so they're not gonna take the total
amount it's kind of like instead of
saying i made a thousand dollars
i only you know to the government
they're saying well
you 500 of that you keep tax-free and
the other 500 of it if your
tax rate is like 25 will tax 25
of the other half oh sorry so they so
okay so they take fifty percent
and then they tax that fifty percent
yeah all right
okay fine yeah yeah so so you know at
the end of the day
you know taxes suck right nobody likes
taxes they suck
but if people do i gotta just put that
out there i've seen on twitter but
anyway
i suppose so yeah but at the end of the
day i'm when i'm looking at it i'm like
am i if i'm paying a capital gains tax
that means
i've i've got there's two routes i could
have gone i could have
saved my dollars and they could have
been depreciated
from beneath me and i could have gotten
effectively nothing for that
or i could have saved my bitcoin if
i need if i when i decide to convert it
or
spend it there is a gain on that and
then i'm paying
tax on that but just by the fact that
i'm paying tax it means
i'm already better off than i was
had i just held the dollars oh i'm
i'm absolutely with you i think you're
absolutely jumping through
through hoops but it's worth it um
instead of having your money just
sitting there and
losing value and the thing is like we
don't we don't talk about that hidden
tax at all we don't talk about it
um and i think it's the most to know
when you go into crypto
um especially for someone at my age
because i'm in my 20s so
cryptocurrency really is the first time
i sort of went
into crypto and then i understood
finance right so it was the other way
around just because of
just because of just because of my age
and so on so it's just so fascinating
because nobody talks to you about
inflation nobody sort of says to you
okay you know you can work for nine to
five and just because you save
and just because you're not greedy and
you're good doesn't mean that you're
going to be rich at the end of the day
um you know i and i know this might
sound ridiculous but for me i just think
it says it all but some people will sort
of say
you know that's inflation but my
grandfather bought his house
back in 1950s for
three thousand pounds um i yeah i just
and now i think it's worth i don't know
like he doesn't like the north of
england so i don't know maybe it's worth
like three hundred thousand pounds or
something like that
um it blows my mind but nobody talks
about it
yeah it was crazy because i mean you you
see it in some basic items
but it's you see a lot of inflation in
assets
things like housing things like stocks
like
the stock market rally is not
at so much of a rally as it is
assets that shelter you from inflation
inflating themselves right so it's it's
kind of
when new money money gets created you've
got to look at where that money flows to
if it just flowed out equally to
everybody
then it would kind of be like a zero-sum
game
because your percentage of the pie money
is just kind of meant to measure
all of the goods and services in an
economy
if everybody's percentage of the pie
remained the same but everybody just
like added a zero to how many dollars
you have
you're no worse or no better than you
were before it doesn't matter
but it's because money gets printed and
then funneled to
certain people that that wealth gap
keeps growing and you see
you know things like assets where your
grandfather was able to use three
thousand pounds which
you know obviously takes a while to to
save up but
you you could have done it um uh
he was able to purchase that house and
now
people lock in for 30-year mortgages to
do the same thing
um so it's it's really
it's very we're fueled by debt to attain
the same standard of living that people
used to have
and just because we're kind of you know
technology has moved quicker so we have
all these cool gadgets and everything
and uh you know we we have nice homes
and things like that if you can afford
one
but to attain that same level every year
it's harder and harder to do so and the
inflation that gets
told to us those levels are far
from the truth like in canada here there
was statscan did a study and they said
oh inflation's only been
0.5 percent for the past few years
which is total trash because when they
count inflation
they don't include food they don't
include fuel
or homes like housing all of those
important things that you kind of really
need day to day they don't count those
things so if you
actually want to know what inflation is
at or get a better picture of it there's
a really good
website called the chapwood index and
this actually breaks it down city by
city i think just in the u.s
but it takes the top 500 items
that the average person in that locale
purchases day to day
and it adds up the inflation of those
over the calendar year
so if you want to see what actually
people are spending and the
real inflation that they experience just
to maintain their standard of living
it's closer to 12 a year it's crazy
and that's not even including like
assets like like stocks and stuff like
that
and i think you know even a number like
that i just don't think it would be
enough to wake people up because
at the end of the day if you're not
taught something you're just not gonna
know it
and that is why i personally feel so
privileged to
have fallen into this space because i
actually didn't initially choose to be
here
um and then and then i decided to stay
um
so i i just i i think i'm so i just feel
so privileged honestly to
to be here and to be aware of these
things because like we said it's that
hidden tax
and you know just because you save it it
really doesn't mean anything
but speaking of bitcoin i feel like
we've got to talk about it we've got to
talk about the market
so gosh we've got it's been a bit of a
ride hasn't it so we passed the all-time
high
and then we did all-time high after
all-time high and then we hit 42k
that was fab and then we retraced what
was it like 28
some people are expecting 27k
so just give us your thoughts yeah well
i mean
if we look historically at kind of what
happened last time around in the bull
run
2017 it's pretty par for the course
um in fact we've been shy of
the pullbacks that we've seen previously
so through the whole bull run of 2017
there were
seven pullbacks in and around in some
cases up to like
38 around 40 somewhere in that realm
happened seven times over uh we haven't
hit that i think
hitting that would have been closer to
25 or 26k
in that realm would have been that
pullback maybe that happens
maybe it doesn't i'm not sure but
even still if we were to drop to 26k in
a few days
i wouldn't be particularly worried about
it um
the other thing to think about is if if
you think that history
will rhyme then you got to look at the
lengths of those pullbacks too
and some of them were as long as 55 days
uh you know some of them were kind of
like i'd say between
40 and 55 days was kind of the average
and so far it's been about 20. so
we're kind of like smack dab in the
middle of that if
history rhymes then within a few weeks
we might see us right back up there
at 42 and then blowing through it so
time will tell if this feels very
familiar to me it feels like a rehash
um but i i'm i'm not freaking out about
this at all i've just been
sitting back and really enjoying yeah
yeah literally i think um yeah i mean
it's pretty it's been pretty insane
because people aren't really sure which
kind of market we're in right i think
you and i are like bull market and then
i think it was cnn that put out the
headline that was uh
28 crash now we're in an hour in a bear
market um i mean
you know bitcoin sort of moving sideways
so how long does it need to move
sideways for until we sort of determine
there's a bear market
if we don't get that you know corrupt
correction and we just guess it's really
corrected but it doesn't go back up to
uh
yeah well first off cnbc or cnn is cnn
yeah okay so they're measuring they're
measuring bear market
by by the traditional definition of it
which is a
20 drop okay if that's their measurement
then we had
seven bear markets during 2017. so
you know take that that as with a grain
of salt
um you know if if we sat at
kind of this level if we traded sideways
for like
four months or something i'd be like uh
it's definitely different maybe
maybe things take longer now maybe it's
it's not going to be those
kind of quick ups and downs i'm doubtful
i you know some i've seen some people
saying how this time it's going to be
different we've got
you know institutional interests
different kinds of money coming in
and so there's you know we're not going
to see
that eventual bear market hmm i don't
know
companies are still run by people i
think we're still going to see
the crazy volatility i think we're still
going to see
the kind of run that we saw in 2017 i
don't know to what extent but
you know the calls of like multiple
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
a lot of different institutions and
individuals i don't think those are
unreasonable whatsoever
i would not be surprised to see him i'd
be very excited it's one thing talking
about it versus experiencing it
um but what if we were to get to those
levels
yeah absolutely i could easily see us
seeing like another
60 70 80 bear market um that
dragged on for another couple of years
but then if we survive that then
next time instead of institutions it's
nation states right like
it i think i think we're just it repeats
it repeats it repeats
it's like watching groundhog day with
bill murray where he wakes up and it's
the same day
every day uh yeah it's that it's that
but it's for your
bitcoin epochs yeah no i'm with you um
yeah i i think i think it's i think it's
exciting i think um i think it was
samson mao that said
um you know on the run up to 100k we're
gonna get these 20 30
pullbacks um when things were running
back in
i said back in january earlier earlier
in january um
people were 100k this year 100 q1 2021
you know
sort of predicting it at the end of q1
let's say like march i'm not gonna ask
for a price prediction um
but give one if you feel um but do you
think that 100k is even likely this year
i mean i think 100k is likely
in the grand scheme of life um but in
the grand scheme of 2021
is it how um how likely do you think it
is
if somebody's top target is 100k this
year i think they're bearish
like that's that's my sentiment like
that's again and i could be wrong
like it could be like people say and
it's gonna be more drawn out
but yeah i don't i don't think so
everything seems to be very similar to
and like we're barely we're like 50
above the all-time high at one point we
had doubled the all-time high
in 2017 we went from 1k
to 20 in the course of a calendar year
we did it basically
if you actually look at like the
all-time high it was around 1200 so we
did like a
17 x or something like that easily
in in 2017 the difference now
is that you have institutions actually
draining
liquidity from exchanges and actually
keeping it on their books which means if
retail fomo hits
then how how do exchanges handle that
it's like you there just won't be enough
so could we see a mania to multiple
hundred thousands
yeah like if the conditions are right
you know what happens when there's a
wall street bet
sentiment on shorting the dollar and
buying bitcoin
i'm so ready for that i'm ready for that
me too because someone there because
don't just put a request into reddit for
me but i like i like that you're bullish
i need to
let my brother know actually because he
brought in at 40k bless him um
so but he's good he's calm he's chill
he's smart he knows he's in it for the
long run so it's chill
um so let's talk about institutions and
jumping into bitcoin because i think
that has what has made everything very
different this time around
um michael stella has obviously sort of
taken the lead with that
but an interesting thing that i want to
talk about is how
important is that do you think for the
price so what happens
um if michael sailor turns around and
says you know
i've made enough i bought in the average
price i brought in
bought in was at let's say 15 16 17k the
average price
um any leaves i don't think he will
but what happens if he leaves are we are
we sort of resting
on institutions um
i mean yeah well people with a lot of
money
can afford to move the price currently
right
that you know if if somebody's moving
you know he was he was able to
strategically
position himself in the market without
moving it too much
um you know and so i think we're still
kind of at that stage but liquidity
is indeed drying up now what turn what
happens when
one's institution turns around and dumps
well one already did
um because of the flood and maybe we'll
get that to that later but there you
know there's a double spin flat article
and
one of the companies that bought um that
bought some bitcoin
i think they bought like 100 and
something bitcoin and then they dumped
it
um are we immune to that kind of stuff
no
obviously not again companies are run by
people and
people can do stupid things sometimes um
what happens if michael saylor turns
around and sells well he sells it to
somebody who wants it more than him
uh so you know do
you do you know if michael saylor is
selling his bitcoin
and all the bitcoiners are buying it
back up
well are they going to give it up later
like whose hands
who are they transferring bitcoin to
right now
you have people that sold 40k
um and you have guggenheim which was
projecting 400
000 bitcoin that isn't allowed to buy
until the end of january
saying well we hit 35k which was a
technical
turnaround point so maybe time to take
some money off the table screw you guys
you guys can't buy yet you said 400k
you're just wanting the market to dip so
that you can
buy some cheap corn like that's well
didn't they predict
they were the ones that predicted 20k
the other day now
yeah yeah yeah they predicted 20k the
other day and i'm like
you i'm like i did a video about it on
top i was like come on like
you everybody knows you want to buy
bitcoin and now you're predicting 20k
yeah they know you want to buy and they
know you can't buy yet
what like show me the incentives and
i'll show you the outcome this is
exactly what you would expect from
somebody like that
that is waiting to buy in the sidelines
and can't yet
they're gonna say some stuff to maybe
kind of
wink wink nudge nudge like yeah it's
let's slap
i said it but i didn't say it kind of
thing yeah um
okay so you mentioned the fun that's
something i also want to talk to you
about so
for those that missed it give us the
lowdown what happened
okay so uh bit max research
noticed something funky on the
blockchain where there appeared to be
uh coins that were spent in two places
at once
and somebody kind of caught on to this
and the headline was effectively
bitcoin may be broken because somebody
was able to spend their money
twice this is not correct and so let me
just kind of give
give you an idea of what actually
happened so so bitcoin itself
is kind of all about obtaining consensus
on who owns what and that can take
different amounts of time
typically within a single block or 10
minutes
you get an updated state of the ledger
of who owns what
okay and you can be fairly certain that
that's how it's gonna be
and that moving forward as more blocks
of transactions are added to that it
it becomes very difficult to change that
on occasion
two miners at the same time will
mine a block of transactions so there
may be slightly different transactions
in one
than the other and at this point you're
never quite sure which transactions are
going to be
officially added to the bitcoin
blockchain in what order
and so it takes until the next block of
transactions
is mined where you can be reasonably
sure okay well this is going to be the
chain moving forward
that happened but in that happening
somebody also used a feature of bitcoin
called
rbf or replace by fee and this allows
you to broadcast a transaction
and if you decide that it's one it's
taking too long you can add a bigger fee
or if you'd like to change where those
funds are going you can actually
add a higher fee in the hopes that that
transaction will get picked up instead
so somebody was sending money to a
wallet they changed their mind about the
amount and where they wanted that money
to go
so they used rbf or replace by fee to
broadcast another version of that
transaction that went somewhere
somewhere else at the same time they did
that
both transactions were mined separately
in those separate blocks
so there was a period in time where we
weren't sure which one was going to be
official
and as soon as the next block was mined
it was official
that this was the winning transaction
and that one was no longer valid
so just a quick question i'm just going
to jump in so when you say
you know one one transaction here one
transaction so it was the same
coin asking for a different thing
yeah it was it was hey i originally
wanted to send my coins here and i
broadcast that
and it was mined but then i also had
broadcast an alternative transaction and
that one was mined
separately at the same time and so
for a moment in time we weren't sure
which one was going to be the official
transaction
it turns out that the lower fee one
actually won funny enough
but anyways as soon as that next block
was mined
the old transaction was no longer valid
and was gone
and so this is actually just how bitcoin
works it's all just
waiting until you can be sure
of where the funds are it's all about
the consensus of who owns what so
the people that were freaking out about
it just didn't understand how bitcoin
worked
and it was literally a function of the
network
okay that's pretty interesting um so
at the end so yeah at the end of it
really it's all about what was confirmed
and only one was confirmed yeah
yeah exactly yeah so so now there's uh
it's called an orphan block
so that's what it was they were they
were
valid transactions at the time but based
on where the chain went
they're no longer that block is no
longer valid it just kind of sits there
and is not included in the bitcoin
blockchain
okay so speaking of fud um there's also
been some tether fud
um could you clear that one up for us
because i think you are
very eloquent in the way that you uh
explain these confusing things so
let's get on to tether yeah so tether i
mean
it's such a rehash of everything we're
in the 20s this is why i think that it's
going to be the same
as 2017 because even the fud is just
like repeating it's on repeat
well tether you know there's always been
rumors that
effectively tether is a stable coin that
is printed from nothing to
specifically to pump the price of
bitcoin that's that's kind of the
general thesis behind it
um for a long time there were rumors
that tether was not back
one to one by dollars they refuted that
claim
eventually they actually did move to a
model where they say they can have
dollars or
equivalent value assets and so
i mean the number one question is tether
backed one to one by
dollars or equivalent i mean i don't
know for sure
i have no idea but let's kind of
reel it back and look at the
implications of what people are saying
tether designed specifically to pump
bitcoin
and you know that's that's why it's
created there
so if that's the case why did they stop
in 2018
2019 and only restart in 2020 like
that's that's the first question like
why
stop if it was working why stop because
tether has been around for a while
um the other principle that i want to
touch on
is just because let's say
let's say that all the rumors are true
let's say tether
effectively had nothing and we're
printing fake dollars
i mean one that's already happening with
the real dollars so
but let's let's try let's draw a
comparison to
let's say dollars in gold
because they've printed so many dollars
over since we went off the gold standard
in 71
does that make gold any less valuable
now
at the time when we went off the gold
standard it was 35 dollars were worth
uh one gold one ounce of gold now it's
around two thousand
because we've printed so much money
you know is is gold less valuable
because
more dollars exist to represent it in my
opinion
it's kind of you found a sly way to get
somebody to hand over a valuable asset
in exchange for
a non-valuable asset um
but i very much doubt that tether
single-handedly
drives the price of bitcoin because if
that was the game
they would at one point have to exchange
that bitcoin for dollars if that's what
their game plan was
uh i i just don't see it okay you know i
i
it not all of it adds up to me it seems
like it's just garbage food
yeah no no i i get that and i think a
lot of this stuff has already been um
dispelled in the last few weeks
um but you know it's good to go over so
speaking of um
fudd and i guess people that don't like
bitcoin
um let's bring up our best friend peter
schiff
so so someone like peter schiff
what is going on you know because he's
kind of making okay of course he's made
a name for himself because of gold like
i'm not gonna um i'm not gonna dispute
that but
he's also making a name for himself for
being this anti-bitcoin
person um somebody who says you can't
buy anything with bitcoin and then
lets you buy things on his website using
cryptocurrencies which is fun
so do you even where does this hate come
from um
a part of me phil's i think he owns
bitcoin what do you think
i i don't i don't think he owns bitcoin
to be honest
uh his son does his son yeah his son
does i love that is
his so spencer his son definitely does
and i love that
so you know i i always say whenever i'm
talking about peter schiff and his son
i say you know short shift gold and long
shift sats because i want his son to
create a company called shift sats
i think that would be poetic but besides
the fact
you know peter schiff is he's just
entrenched right like his whole life has
been dedicated
to a lot of the fundamental reasoning
why that drive bitcoiners and why we
believe in bitcoin
but he can't fathom the idea that
something has come along
and done what gold does but better and
has corrected
the the weaknesses in gold that led to
the abolition
of the gold standard right it was it was
physical it was easily centralized and
it wasn't easily divisible so we had to
abstract away
via paper notes and that led to people
creating more paper notes than gold
bitcoin you don't have that problem
because it's just so divisible
and even when you get down to a single
sat level you jump to lightning network
and you can divide those
so you know it's it it does away
with that inherent centralization now do
people leave
bitcoin on exchanges absolutely but
easily auditable as well
so like if you have a bunch of funds
that buy a bitcoin
and they all claim to have you know x
amount of bitcoin you start doing the
math and it adds up to 30 million
bitcoin
you know something's up and you might
want to pull out your money very quickly
so yeah like i i he's just a perma bear
and it's because of his entrenched
interest i actually i framed a tweet of
his hold on
no he did oh my god i framed it in gold
so this he tweeted this on january 6th
of 2020
and he said for those bitcoin bugs
excited about bitcoin's 4
rally in 2020 think about this gold is
also up by about the same percentage
this year
only with significantly less downside
risk if this is the best rally bitcoin
can muster
how will it ever hit 50k let alone 1
million
and this thing is aging like like
milk like it's it's hilarious
how bad of a call this what like four
percent up we were like
seven or eight k when he tweeted
wait well what date was that this was
january 6 of 2020.
oh i thought you said 2021 yeah that was
beautiful my brother wow this has been
sitting on my shelf for a year and it's
gonna sit there for many more
wait you need you need to like have you
told him or am i
does he know oh yeah i tweet i tweet him
all the time i take like pictures of me
on my pillow snuggling it
it's great i love it i love the i love
the cool
for um 50k that's brilliant because one
year later we were just
8 000 away yeah my guess
my guess is that that that tweet
part of it the first call is obliterated
this year and then within five years
the second call is obliterated that's
wild i freaking love that that's so
funny
um but speaking of all of all this stuff
then it'll be really cool to hear
um your thoughts on bitcoin's place um
in
i always feel like saying the world to
come that sounds really weird um it
sounds like some religious
way of saying it but in the next few
decades where do you see bitcoin you
know you mentioned the lightning network
but people will often say
bitcoin can't scale the lightning now
because a failed um project and so on so
it's a store of value is it a global
reserve currency is it a day-to-day
payments um solution
what is bitcoin these days or what's it
going to be
eventually all of those things um
yeah but i think you've got to have
priorities and you've got to
protect the the base layer
so that it can become all of those
things and
that means that baseline transactions
may
at times be expensive so again i've
already kind of alluded to it in the
show but i live on bitcoin
so and people say that it's unusable and
you can't use it day to day i
literally do it every day so
you're wrong um but besides
you're wrong um so you know like what am
i interested in
first and foremost well i want sound
money i want a separation of money and
state
i want censorship resistance i want
immutability
of the actual underlying code so that i
know the rules governing it that say
it's limited can't be screwed with and
can't be easily changed
um you know i want it's secured
via you know a consensus algorithm that
is not easily gamed
so for me the only viable
option for that is proof of work because
it's prohibitively
expensive to attack the network and then
i want it to be easily verifiable
via my own node which i'm running a
bitcoin node right behind me and all of
my wallets connect to that
and i also want it to be leaderless like
i don't want
to see the ceo plastered i don't want to
see
the the creator placer somewhere i don't
want them to be able to
influence the market because in a lot of
instances when there's a figurehead or
there's a foundation
when they say jump everybody holding it
says how high
and so they get in these kind of
deity-like positions where they can
influence it even if they don't intend
to so
i want all of those things and when i
take that litmus test and i test it
against anything outside of bitcoin
i don't see it it's it doesn't tick all
of those boxes for me and so that's why
i'm centered around bitcoin
yeah i get that i think um i think it's
interesting
a lot of bitcoins do say they they see
bitcoin becoming everything
um i definitely wholeheartedly see
bitcoin as gold 2.0
as that store of value um as that way to
opt out
um i i'm not saying no but i for me i'm
yet to sort of
be fully convinced and i'm really
excited to see if bitcoin really could
be the global reserve currency if it
really could be
um that day-to-day payment solution and
because if so
then that's that's amazing you know if
we could be like paying taxes and
bitcoin and
just keeping everything in bitcoin um
because right now like you said jumping
through hoops it is a lot so
ideally that's what i would also like i
just i'm not 100 but i'm
so excited i'm so excited to find out
yeah i i you know
it's not a for sure thing like obviously
it's not 100 certain that's going to
happen
um i think we're leaning that way
but i guess to answer your previous
question of where is it going i think we
have to go after that store of value
and secure that kind of like reasoning
on the base layer first
before we can easily obtain those other
things
like easy day-to-day payments now i use
lightning network every day
is it like the easiest thing in the
world well it's gotten a hell of a lot
easier since i first used it two years
ago um
you know they you can auto swap in and
out and it's still cheap and fast
but you know there's work to be done
obviously but i'm not as concerned about
having to jump through those hoops as
long as
the the sanctity of that base layer
value proposition as sound money that is
separate from the state
is maintained and all of those things
that i just talked about i think are
entirely necessary to be preserved in
order to attain that
okay so coming towards the end of this
um you can answer this one
quickly because then i want to talk
about you and what you're working on
next
um but i want to know your opinion on
which cryptocurrency you think
is going to take us mainstream so i
think things are going to go mainstream
um you're probably going to say bitcoin
but i'm going to ask you anyway
um things are gonna go mainstream i hear
is gonna be the year i hear that from a
tech perspective um i hear it from a
fundamentals perspective and then i also
hear from like a spiritual perspective
you know i'm here in 2023 as a year
um so which cryptocurrency is going to
do it um i mean doge is a bit of a meme
um things like link are doing some
really things like link uh
coins the the coin link sounds kind of
weird when i say it
link is doing some really cool stuff so
which crypto do you think will take us
mainstream and what are your thoughts
i mean you called my answer yes bitcoin
um
again i'm not i'm not super convinced by
anything else
given the the criteria that i laid out
so like
okay let's let's take link for instance
um
you know a lot of that has to do with
pulling off chain
data pulling uh data in the real world
from oracle's and putting that onto the
blockchain
so with that it you know
you can't get past the fact that data
bad data can in some circumstances
be put onto the blockchain it's
it's possible to have bad data input
when you're taking it from a real world
source
and so if that actually gets onto a
blockchain
then some of that data on the blockchain
which is meant to be kind of a beacon of
truth
becomes incorrect if you can go back and
amend that data and correct it
then why are you using a blockchain in
the first place
so i i've always kind of gotten i've
never been sold on
on kind of this real world off chain
data
on chain as as a use case because
and the supply chain stuff because the
inputs
can potentially be bad and if you can
fix those inputs to make them correct
then
a blockchain is completely useless to
you so
but just on that point though i mean i
wouldn't say entirely useless because
you know they're using things like smart
contracts and
decentralized exchanges and all these
sorts of things that we need blockchain
for but i understand how the information
can be incorrect
but what if they're able to get to a
point whereby
they make sure that it's not incorrect
well i mean how do you do that so like i
i know that
there's there's mechanisms to to
um you know with link the they'll be and
with other chains there'll be mechanisms
to try to
penalize people that do do things
maliciously
um what happens in instances of like
civil attack where the vast majority of
people agree to
collude together to do do things that
are not
necessarily true you know like there's
attack vectors that can be had there
um i just i haven't been convinced with
off chain data
being used on chain i think the reason
that something like bitcoin works
is because it's purely digital it's a
native digital asset
and so you don't need to audit what's in
the real world in order to know that
what's in front of you is true
um so yeah like i
again i'll i'll listen to different
things when people pitch it but i
haven't heard
very different pitches as of yet and so
i'm kind of
i don't know i i'll i'll say that
my skepticism is is thought through
i'm always open to hearing other things
but to date
when i list off the criteria where i
think that something is valid
i just haven't seen that opposing
argument yet
yeah no i i get that i think i mean i'm
definitely
bitcoin for me is definitely number one
i definitely do see
the i do see um blockchain technology
being used
um outside of sort of the bitcoin
landscape um i'm definitely someone who
sort of sees
the use case of it and in countries that
don't have
the kind of financial infrastructure
that we have in terms of you know
getting mortgages and loans and things
like that you know like i get
i get the d5 craze i get it um but it's
still super new it's
super experimental you know i'm with you
in terms of
it hasn't proven itself entirely because
like you said
there are still holes um in sort of
making sure that the blockchain is doing
what the blockchain is supposed to do
immutable accurate transparent and so on
um so i'm with you i'm yet i'm yet to
see so just finally this has been a
fantastic
chat um but finally what are you up to
and also where can people find you so
just promote yourself
yeah uh so i mean i've been doing uh
tutorials on my youtube channel since
2016 now so it's going on
five years um so i do multiple videos a
week whether it be tutorials or
one-on-one interviews or panel shows so
i always do those um
you can find me just searching btc
sessions on youtube
you can find me on twitter at btc
sessions
and uh you can find my website btc
sessions.ca
that canadian uh canadian uh suffix
there so yeah um
you can find me all over the place and
yeah i'm just doing my thing i'm i'm
making shows and enjoying being around
and doing what i love
well i want to thank you so much for
coming on um you're an absolutely
fantastic guest you're
so eloquent um you explained everything
beautifully
um and i i think it's so important to
break down these complex topics because
for some people
um you know we hear double spend and you
know people think oh yeah yeah
i get it but a lot of people don't um
especially what's going on
with gamestop and robin hood and why
that matters to our community
so thank you so much for coming on thank
you for having me
and guys thank you so much for watching
and thank you to my sponsors we will see
you next thursday bye